Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace.
Man over wings is such a wondrous thing.
Behind the deuce of rumsy, come take your place.
We're leaving soon.
Vibrations, maybe it's the power source.
It's probably the power generator for the city.
Could be in this area.
Would have to be enormous, wouldn't it?
I'm thinking of Murdoch.
Poor fellow's probably dead out there.
You can think of him, but now's not the time.
What happened exactly?
What's your analysis of the situation, Metro?
No analysis possible, not enough data.
I believe that I do have sufficient grasp of the situation to suggest that we are not among friends.
Notice.
Looks like those robots, well, looks like they're not programmed to detect us.
Instantly, my friend.
Message received.
Encountering Omega ship in 20 minutes, great computer.
What are your orders?
Activate preparations for receiving our guests.
Question, Colonel, regarding our outer perimeter defense system.
there was a local activation. What was that?
The power network was overloaded
at takeoff. We suppose it resulted
in certain short circuits. I see.
This must be rectified in future.
Yes, great computer.
You're still worried? Yes, I am, maestro.
Our children. What's happened to them?
What about them? Yes, yes, of course,
it's worrying, but with this ship, you'll be able
to meet any eventuality we encounter.
Colonel, a massive asteroid is directly
in our flight path. It's rather curious, sir.
It's coming straight for us and not spinning.
Our computer maintains it's discovered
a source of heat combustion. Colonel, it's a spaceship. A spaceship of that size? No.
So surely there's no such ship. Maximum power on the observation screen. Fire a sunlight rocket
to light it up. Welcome you to our nebula, visitors from Omega. Men from Omega. Welcome
you as friends. We request you follow our instructions very carefully and of prime
importance. We give you our unequivocal promise that no harm will come to you, but we must
insist on one condition. At the slightest hostile action on your part, we will be obliged to
destroy you. So far, so good. Got any idea where Psyche is? It would seem that we are going in the
right direction generally, but this place is so strange I cannot be sure of anything. Well,
you'd better figure it out soon. I can't take it much longer in this tin suit. In that case,
I would suggest you. Specialists has devised a special treatment that will cure you. Please
cooperate. Oh, Mr. Nuts and Bolts, the treatment is over. Exactly, it's over. Except for one little
dose of your own medicine. And already? No, Pio. We're traveling out in space. In space, you say?
A whole building in space?
Not only a building, Piero. The entire city.
Yes, sorry about that. I knew what that rumbling was. It had to be a ship taking off, but I didn't think it was the right time to talk about it.
Good old Metro. What would we do without you?
Long way, but I found you. How do they treat you here?
Piero, I'm fine now that you're here. Now that you're both here. But you know, it's curious. For a little while now, I've had the feeling that there are friends nearby, and not just you two.
Here? In the city, you mean?
Mm-hmm.
I don't wish to spoil the mood, but if they are here, shouldn't we set about finding them?
Eh?
These are the senior officers of our spaceship.
Maestro is our leading scientist, and I am Colonel Pierre, chief of the Omega Intergalactic Police.
Why can't we see you?
Because I am a computer.
I am the great computer.
I am present in all parts of this city.
I am this city.
I am all that you have seen here and more.
But to give you real beings to talk with, I have produced others like you.
You will feel more comfortable addressing individuals whom you can see.
I shall speak through them.
Well now, Colonel, go on.
Ask your questions.
I shall answer anything you care to ask.
And of course, your questions too, sir.
How is it possible?
How can there be a computer city?
I am electronically linked to all things in all places at all times.
Each of my creations is linked to me.
Even to your soldiers?
To your robots?
No, not to the relatively unimportant ones, workers' tools, such things.
I would like to know who built you, created you, who programmed you.
That is a long story, but surely one that you will have to hear, so I shall tell you.
One day, over three centuries ago, there was a very important meeting on Earth.
And so, once more, our planet is at the brink of chaos, the prey of the ambitious,
the intolerant dictators hungry for conquest.
Our world's survival can be achieved only by the machine, by my machine.
Allow my computer to rule the world.
Allow it to determine all laws in our society.
And without envy or bias, it will peacefully carry out a just and lasting policy
to regulate the affairs of all men.
Peace forever.
Yeah, peace forever.
Peace of the grave.
Why, machines governing the world?
That's immoral.
And would you rather have the morality of human jackals?
There is give and take in human feelings and understanding.
Would you have all human beings classified by machines?
And metaphysics, that superior faculty of man,
have you considered that?
Stuff and nonsense.
You are all idiots.
You are the idiot who can't really stand.
Crazy.
They must be crazy to think I'm crazy.
This is an interesting nebula here.
And it holds endless quantities of metal, I judge.
Go and gather some samples of metals.
All you have to do is pick them up.
Soon we will start constructing a new generator.
And relax then.
To visit the neighbor's vicious animals and worst of all, little food.
I can certainly help you.
If you like, you can come to my planet.
To Yama.
Living conditions are much better there.
You can establish your own base, which will provide you with all your needs.
Healthy robot!
What is it you want, my friends?
Now, you listen, Professor. We think it's wrong what you're doing just making all these good-for-nothing robots
when you ought to use your brains to do what you can for us.
But I do nothing else. You may not understand, but I assure you, everything I do is for you.
I welcome you aboard. Haven't I said that I will do all I can for you, my friends?
You're no friend of ours. Your only friends are machines.
Now, once and for all, will you put your knowledge to our use?
So it all starts again, just as it did back on Earth.
No, I will not aid your ambition.
Watch this!
Attachment of soldiers to construct a base to keep watch over the men there,
otherwise it will start all over again.
You can speak, you will explain it to them.
And should they not agree?
So much the worse for them, you will be armed.
What happens to those few matters?
As you order.
And for a long time thereafter, our city, shielded from men's mad designs,
grew in strength inside the walls.
Control center at its heart.
Concepts that can only elude me.
Expeed attention, your implacable logic.
Men are weak, so weak fight with them to make them accept what is good for them.
It is for that only that I have ever used force, and you are to use force only in that end.
The welfare of mankind.
Remember, it's your only objective.
You seek to give eternal peace to man.
Thy will shall be done.
He died some two centuries ago, since all of us here have remained faithful to his original programming.
Look around you, our entire city has been constructed in his image, for we honor the memory of our crew.
Our city grew in size, developed great resources, all with the objective he set.
And now all our testing has been approaching our goal.
You're testing? What tests?
You are acquainted with some.
In the attempt to take over the Cosmopolitan, was that you?
Yes.
Hold to the robots on the planet Leto as well.
Yes, with the complicity of the Cassiopeians.
We had to practice being around you.
Those were only exercises, maneuvers to perfect our technique.
Cassiopeia's an ally of yours.
An ally when it suited us.
They think they are manipulating us, but they do our bidding.
You don't know General Grouchley, I'm afraid.
You do not know me, Colonel.
General is a driven, frustrated creature dominated by his insane desire to rule the universe.
He is exactly the sort of man against whom I must defend humanity.
And you, you'd carry it out at all costs?
I will carry out my duty at all costs.
The rocket bomb against the Earth, was that you?
It was us with help from Cassiopeia.
And so, you would have destroyed the Earth.
It was the General's intention, not ours.
Contrary to our own interests.
No, we wanted only to measure your capacity to resist our attack.
Had you surrendered, valuable time would have been saved.
In any case, our bomb was not programmed to explode. It would have caused no harm.
I would like to know our reconnaissance vehicle, Hummingbird, that happened to come into your nebula.
What happened to it?
It crashed accidentally on planet Apis. It is our sister planet.
What? And what about its crew?
Wounded, we located the young lady and have tried to cure her.
Our best doctors are caring for her. One minute, I will get a report on her condition.
What about the young man?
Captain Piero, unfortunately, was lost attempting to cross the dangerous swamps of planet Aptis.
The part of my death is premature, great computer.
Piero.
Oh, well, I'm used to this.
In all these emotional scenes, everybody's hugged except you know who.
I assure you I am pleased to know that you have recovered one who was lost, Colonel.
No thanks to the treatment you subjected me to.
My regrets.
For us, all that counts is the final result.
The tranquility of the universe, the lot of certain individuals, is of no interest.
us and a lot of some thousands of individuals judging from the way the yaman people are allowed
to live the condition of even thousands cannot matter well then what do you want may i suggest
that before continuing our discussion we make a brief tour of the city i believe you will understand
better fantastic masters spaceship enshrined in a crystal as a mausoleum in a word incredible it's
the only word may find it even more unbelievable this block is composed of 40 stories here too
what I am. Billion upon billion, integrated circuit, data storage files, controlling a universe
posed to billions of individuals. This is beyond belief. There it is. There is perhaps no need to
show you our factories, our weapons. You have already gathered enough data to judge our power.
These weapons, who taught you how to make them? Your master, of course. No, we possessed only
rudimentary weapons. But when General Grouchley asked us to manufacture them, I realized how
possession of these arms could accelerate the process of achieving our goal. And did he share
all of his secrets with you? Not intentionally. The general takes himself for a very clever fellow.
He tried to keep secret certain critical data. We were able to extrapolate and interpolate and in
the end we were able not only to perfect his weapons but to improve them, amplify them. Today
we manufacture weapons as powerful as we wish. Power to infinity. Once again my question is what
do you want of us? Despite his extraordinary capacity for knowledge man is in his infancy.
he refuses to grow to maturity.
War is still for him a game in which he can give full reign to his baser instincts.
This we cannot allow.
We will not allow mankind to be subjected to suffering or privation.
Under our governance, all source of conflict will be eliminated.
If Grouchly weren't around, there wouldn't be conflict.
There is a Grouchly in every man.
What I've seen of your governance is less convincing than your words.
And what I was made to suffer doesn't reassure me either.
You are confused.
To achieve our objective, we must be effective.
and more cruel than the cruelty you claim to be fighting millions of years ago you humanity came
out of your caves and what has happened your instincts what real human progress have you made
here you may judge for yourself what we have accomplished in less than three centuries one
moment one moment you were created programmed by a man you are not going to tell me that a creation
can be greater than what created it right our creator was an exceptional man hence we are
exception. As for man, it requires only a planet, an ocean, a sun, and there are 200 billion in our
galaxy alone. All this and in time man emerges as the final link in the chain, and for all of this
he may still consider himself unique. Precisely, man is unique. He alone in creation can abstract
from his experience. He alone believes in what he cannot see. All your abstract beliefs are to give
a meaning to your existence. Only man can laugh, sing, do what he will for fun, not out of necessity.
Whoever saw a robot compose a Mozart sonata or a Beethoven quartet?
It could be done.
But what would be the point?
All music is no more than man's effort to lose himself in infinity.
It is a delusion, a dream, an escape.
I do believe I have heard that someplace before.
I repeat, you must submit to our government.
In any case, you have no choice.
According to my calculations, chances are 99.99 in our favor in the event of conflict.
Allow me to show you what you would face.
Any planet.
No, that's not necessary. I can certify to its power. I've seen it in action.
All sorts of weapons. Our protection shield field of force is totally invulnerable, as you will have observed.
If you say so.
Really have to extend your power over a few more rocks in the sky, the Confederation of Omega?
Haven't you enough? All those billions of other systems in the galaxy?
We have no choice. Otherwise, the germ of man's aggression will still live, and one day man will again threaten the...
You are worse than those you would blame.
But we have neither ambition, nor passion, nor madness.
Why not accept? You know quite well that you will not be allowed to choose.
Don't make us inflict any harm.
We here are not authorized to engage the Confederation in any such decision.
In my opinion, they'll never accept.
Yes. In all honesty, their acceptance is highly unlikely.
But it's only logical. You do realize that you would have no chance against us.
Yes, I'll admit that. However, in no way does that change what I have just said.
Very well. Return home. Carry my message with you. Tell them what you have seen.
We will come soon to know your answer. We will arrive in force.
First, we have a matter to settle. I understand that Cassiopeia is no longer a member of your confederation.
But go now, free.